let's get a gander at the may 2013 issue
of Reason magazine with reason
editor-in-chief Matt Welch welcome back
Matt thank you for welcome me to my own
office no problem alright so there were
some really interesting articles in this
issue and one of them I think that was
most terrifying to me was about the
medical profession codes acronyms and
protocols killing creativity and
intuition in medicine it's alarming and
sad tell me about that article we have a
great libertarian doctor in Arizona dr.
Jeff singer who talks about how all the
standardization of Medicare and Hospital
practices and now Obamacare have created
a perverse system whereby doctors are
out there trying to fill in codes codes
that will reimburse them more strongly
rather than tailoring their own
diagnosis and their own prescriptions to
what the patient needs it's created a
very standardized cookie cutter way of
producing medicine and it's turned
doctors from sole proprietors and
entrepreneurs into more like button
pushers and and an employee's of
hospitals it's really changed the system
so that doctors are no longer satisfied
and happy with their jobs in the subhead
of the of the piece he's talking about
how doctors are actually going galt they
are leaving the profession because of
the strictures placed upon it by the
central government it's scary because
patients lose and medical schools will
too because there's no longer incentive
for people to go to medical school out a
call and it all gets more expensive for
everybody speaking of expensive we're
finally getting to see what happened
what was the result of the big stimulus
ant research dance software and the
multiplier the stimulus 833 billion
dollars in 2009 was sold to us as if you
spend one dollar of stimulus you'll get
something like one and a half dollars
maybe two dollars in economic activity
which will then reboot the economy and
it's all going to be happy days and
cupcakes after that that didn't turn out
to be true we all know that what Peter
Suderman has done is he's talked about
why the theory of the multiplier to
begin with was false and unknowable
unprovable you can't really measure a
stimulus as effect because you can't
just have an entire separate economy as
a control group on this on any other
convenient metric though for the Obama
administration well sure to sell it and
not only that but they may
the Congressional Budget Office measure
it even though they can't and so they
measured it based on the myth of the
multiplier and said well this is
probably creating or saving three and a
half million jobs even though our own
ways of measuring this cannot possibly
prove that right Wow so every quarter
you see a lot of a journalism basically
saying that CBO approves that's you know
the stimulus is working yet we live in a
world where we can see that the economy
is worse than the worst case scenarios
for the president's own advisors when
they were trying to sell the stimulus
when they said if you don't do the
stimulus we're going to see unemployment
go above eight percent well it's gone
way above that and now we're getting
into more of a japan-style economy and
Peter does a really good job of doing a
post game point by point white oh I'm
wrong even the worst case scenarios came
true with the stimulus yes and now
they're asking for more the Democratic
budget asked for another 100 billion
dollar system oh my garden Matt also has
a great essay the death of contrarian
ISM is journalism worse for the wear
because there is a new New Republic find
out in the may 2013 issue of reason and
for reason TV I'm Kennedy
you